also here tonight hosts a sunday night
in america with trey gowdy got the whole
weekend lineup right here in one show
you gotta love it all right trey you're
a house guy you see how these things
play out it's not just the intelligence
failure that's happened to commanders in
chief in the past it's he ignored the
intelligence and then he gave 600 000
guns to the enemy and then stranded
americans in a war zone with no plan to
rescue them is that a dereliction of
duty in your opinion
well first of all congratulations on yet
another show that's the last thing you
needed was another show on fox but
congratulations i mean legally jesse
yes is malfeasance um is incompetence in
office is that something for which you
can be impeached yes
this is where i disagree i mean the the
reason republicans find themselves where
they find themselves sometimes because
they set expectations so unrealistically
high there is a zero chance that joe
biden is going to be in peace between
now and the midterms and there's really
a zero and there's a zero chance
unless something miraculous happens that
there will be 67 votes to convict him
in the new senate so why don't
republicans focus on what we should be
focused on number one get americans out
of afghanistan get the people who took
us at our word out of afghanistan
protect the women and children
regardless of their nationality and then
once all of
that is done if you can't win the 2022
midterms with the border with
afghanistan and with surging crime then
you don't deserve to be a political
party yeah lindsey graham teed the
impeachment deal up so that's why we're
covering it but you're right we got a
long way to go with this this could get
a lot worse
you got thousands of americans outside
the wire the clocks ticking they're
gonna have to do commando raids to get
these guys or just pay bribes but you're
gonna have phoners from stranded women
and children people screaming people
crying there's no way the bite
administration is going to be able to
ignore that and carter had a hostage
crisis for what a year maybe a little
over
he got three more years left in abiding
term this just isn't going to go away so
if you add this to as you said the open
border to inflation to crt and the
schools to backsliding on mass you get
delta coming up in the fall in the
winter we're talking catastrophe
politically for this guy i just don't
see how he hangs on and i just see
democrats running for the hills
well i think
i think you're right
unless republicans overplay their hands
and let me say this about lindsay
because i spent the weekend with him he
really believes it i mean lindsay's an
air force guy he's a military veteran
he's been to afghanistan this enrages
him and it breaks his heart and it
should do the same for each of us which
makes me kind of wonder how the guy got
elected in the first place i mean it's
not like robert gates didn't warn us
he's always wrong and yet he was elected
anyway so what is possible winning in
the fall of 2022 is possible flipping
the senate is possible and then
nominating someone who can win in 2024
but because i just anyone who thinks
that kamala harris would not be worse
than joe biden has not listened to
kamala harris and then she's going to go
pick a vice president i mean who do you
want you want corey bush do you want a
memory of the squad do you want
elizabeth warren or god forbid do you
want nancy pelosi to ascend from third
in line to second in line to maybe first
in line so
look it's interesting to talk about but
there's a consequence when people used
to ask me why haven't you
impeached barack obama when i was in the
house my answer was always because i met
joe biden that's why so what comes after
him i don't think you're going to like
it any more than you like him well we
got a little breaking news here the u.s
state department has just issued an
alert warning u.s nationals to avoid
traveling to the airport
ask those waiting outside to leave
immediately i mean that tells me there's
an extremely dangerous and deteriorating
security situation at the airport we
don't know what that is that's just
speculation but they're telling
americans don't come to the airport and
if you're there right now to leave
and we're going to follow that and bring
you any updates to that but that does
not sound good trey gowdy everybody
thank you so much thank you jesse hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else